[Musique]
comment ça va pas il faut que je t'amène
à l'hôpital
j'aurais jamais les moyens de payer
cette opération
[Musique]
et vous avez oublié quelque chose
tu es rapide tu cherches un nouveau
travail ça consiste en quoi à reprendre
vous fichez ce qu'ils ont volé aux
pauvres
bienvenue dans la ligue
à l'on dit trop c'est tout c'est leur
but les amis
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce que vous faites j'ai
quelque chose qui vous appartient
est ce que vous diriez de sortir de
votre prison dorée
je vais te faire découvrir la ville
comme tu ne l'a jamais vu
j'aurais aimé que sa vie ne s'arrête
jamais mais je dois te dire quelque
chose mes parents m'ont promise à un
autre
arkadi ma demande et à main
et j'ai dit oui
et ce n'est pas tout
[Musique]
nous allons nettoyer les rues de la
ville de toute cette racaille il est
temps de choisir entre ton destin tout
tracé la liberté
[Musique]
oui tous nous oppose
tu es né dans un palais et moi dans la
rue
et pourtant tout nous pousse l'un vers
l'autre
j'ai vu quelque chose changer dans ton
regard
et j'ai réalisé à quel point tu des plus
une petite fille
[Musique]
on ne vit pas en fonction des règles de
quelqu'un d'autre
écris ta propre histoire
dans la cité des glaces
tous les rêves sont réalisables
[Musique]